hey everyone this is Steve launch hope
with collider and I'm here in obviously
the collider Studio sponsored by
Saratoga spring water thank you Saratoga
costs a lot of money to be here I
appreciate our sponsors
um and I'm here with the great people
behind fancy dance
um I just want to really start with uh
congratulations on being part of
Sundance and making a film uh like I
thought it turned out great and I think
until such an important story but no one
or hardly anyone watching this interview
will have seen the movie yet so how have
you been describing it to like friends
and family
well fancy dance
um uh follows an indigenous queer woman
whose sister has just recently gone
missing and she's left as the unlikely
caretaker to her 13 year old niece and
um it the film follows the two of them
as their kind of relationship Ebbs and
flows as they are you know grappling
with the reality that their sisters
mother is missing
um really this film
um you know we wrote this film as a love
letter to our indigenous communities and
we made the film
um hoping to kind of share the love and
um the connection of human beings and
how that gets them through even some of
the darkest of times
uh one of the reasons why I'm so happy
this film was made is that
um there's just such a lack of coverage
on missing Native Americans and the
stories that it's just it's very
frustrating and so can you sort of talk
a little bit about that aspect that
um no just that if you don't mind
anyone that you meet in Indian country
is touched by this epidemic in some way
or another and it's an epidemic that's
in hundreds of years in the making since
contact and since colonization you know
native communities have been impacted in
all different ways but one of the you
know that we're still facing in such
high numbers today is
um missing and murdering indigenous
women and children and and relatives and
for us we didn't want to like sit too
much in the trauma and too much in the
pain but we wanted to ground the story
in that topic and in these themes
um as a way not to really educate
because the film was kind of meant for
our like I made the film for my
community really but hopefully people
will watch the film and
um kind of understand a little more
about how the ongoing genocide of Native
Americans is ongoing and that it is
still present and it is still happening
every day
um and that there are heroic individuals
that are working inside of communities
providing safety for native people and
in this film two of those heroic people
are are you know Jackson rookie
um for both of you you guys are great
together in the on screen and I'm just
curious if you could talk a little bit
about collaborating and working together
and being part of a film like this which
tells such an important story
okay I mean working with Lily is amazing
and you know I've said this so many
times but like instantly as soon as we
met it just it just clicked it just
worked and getting to tell this story
with Lily is just like such a blessing
and
just you know it's really really
important and it's real and I think that
getting those stories out there is
really important and the fact that we
get to do it together is really cool and
Isabelle is just such a tremendous
person and talent you know young um
Young Folks are
have a lot to say and none are not none
but not many are as eloquent as Isabelle
is she's got some incredible work aside
from this I mean just look her up on
YouTube does a lot of Youth reporting
about indigenous issues in Canada it's a
very smart kid here
um so it was it was wonderful to
you know have somebody that was a
partner in this you know it's like she's
she's become in many ways like a niece
and we did have a great Rapport right
away Erica had impeccable taste in
casting because I've been attached to
this since it was an idea but the the
heart of it was always like who's our
Roki so it was incredible didn't have a
read didn't have anything together
before we were in the studio learning
fancy dance with Holly who played my
missing sister for missing mother she
was also a dance coordinator
um but yeah I think trusting just This
brilliant thoughtful young woman
allowed the work to be what it is kind
of what Erica was saying we didn't want
to live in the trauma we didn't want to
point to the trauma because people can
get addicted to that in a way that they
stop actually caring it's like they care
about caring but they don't care about
what it is they're actually caring about
it's an odd cycle that we get in
so um Isabelle and I also come from
really we're not from the same tribal
Nations but we come from really similar
world view and similar cultural practice
um
and we kind of spoke about this like the
way that we do it the ceremony that we
both take part of
um it's important that you maintain a
levity and a humor and a lightness
when you're in the process of healing
and really what we're doing by telling
these stories is we're doing healing
work because communities who are living
this every day are families who are
living this every day they know how hard
it is you know and like Eric said we
made it for our communities so it's how
are we surviving in this who are the
people that are carrying us through this
and a lot of times it's our it's our
women it's our it's our queer relatives
it's
the Community Builders that are really
marginalized but are holding it together
at the center so knowing that Isabelle
had this
depth and this understanding as a young
actor allowed us both to lean into the
levity and the joy of it which is what
makes this film work really it's what
makes our relationship work I mean if
you look at all of the footage when
we're not doing Jackson rookie it's like
we're both crossing our eyes at the
frame and being stupid
but it was really fun I'm so curious if
you were more nervous about some of the
dialogue and drama scenes or the dancing
I mean the Cayuga I just really wanted
to get it right like I really really
cared about that and I do come from a
dance background so I both do we're both
ballerinas one of our kids yes they're
still doing it I'm a studio dancer and
so I had that kind of coming into it and
I've done some power in the past but
getting to actually really focus on it
for this role was really really fun and
you know I'm still doing powwow I still
it like it helped me find something that
I just truly truly love and really
realize that that was there for me to do
and yeah I loved getting to dance and it
was so fun
um but I was definitely very nervous for
the Cayuga
because I really really cared about it
yeah that's a big responsibility you
know
um bringing that into this world in this
way where this child is growing up
fluent in the language that's something
that's really revolutionary and people
have fought hard for Erica was saying
there's maybe 20
um Cayuga first language speakers left
yeah less than 20 after the pandemic
less than 21st language Cayuga speakers
left and we really wanted to imagine a
world where like young people spoke the
language fluently and so
um it was a challenge but we knew how
important it was and so I've been
through language immersion but we
brought down a speaker Kisa Parker who
worked with them ahead of time and we've
already been getting reviews from Cayuga
speakers that they did an amazing job
speaking kayuga so that's the only
reviews we care about around here
I wanted to make sure people realize
that it's a language that's not uh
spoken by a lot of people and it uh um
can you sort of talk about was that one
of the motivations for making sure that
because you had a choice of what to have
in this movie Why was it important for
Cayuga to be part of this
film came when I was in language
immersion I was doing a three year long
language immersion program in Cayuga
which is my ancestral language and
um when we were learning family words I
learned the mother the word for mother
was kanoha and the word for Auntie is
kanoha ah which directly translates to
small mother your other mother and it
just you know I grew up in my community
I've been a Cuca person since I was born
and but I was it at a as of you know a
person who was 35 years old or whatever
it opened my mind up to like a
completely different side of my culture
through the language and I was seeing
the matrilineal ties the matriarchy I
was seeing the world view through the
sentence structure through the grammar
and that was what sparked the film was
this idea that your aunt is actually
your other mother is your mother and is
as important in raising you and so as
soon as the we started writing the
script we knew that since the
Cornerstone of the film was language
that it had to be present and
you know I love that they speak it when
they're alone together and they kind of
only revert to English when they have to
and then when they are trying to be
intimate when other
people are around they can tell secrets
they can do their heists you know they
can get away with things in the language
and so we had we had a lot of fun using
that
um for not only plot reasons but just
their character and their connection
um I'm curious for all three of you you
obviously made this with a finite a
budget and a limited amount of time so
when you were making it for all three of
you um what was the day of the shoot
that you were like circled on the
calendar in terms of nervous how I'm
going to pull this off how are we going
to get our shots you know what I mean
the
night shoot
yeah that was definitely
we were all kind of waiting for that to
happen that was September 2nd I think oh
yeah we still remember the day yeah
was it just recently like this September
yeah this past September oh wow so when
did you wrap September 26th and in so
October wow that is fast to get this
well I slept last night after the
premiere I was like it's like I can
finally sleep because the movies played
um it was a really fast turnaround and
um you know we had sent it into Sundance
and we were
you know hoping and I the film had gone
through a lot of the labs and when we
got the call for yes I was like oh my
goodness like we have to finish the
movie now but I they you know Sundance
saw something in in in what we sent and
it was a real um uh you know we were
urgently getting it finished and I was
so so glad to get to share it with
everyone last night at Eccles yeah um
also that's such an amazing theater I
wasn't there for the premiere but for
the two of you what was it like being in
that audience I'm assuming you watched a
thousand people uh all taking in what
you spent so much time and energy doing
um it's my second Premiere at Eccles and
it was um
this one particularly felt like I was I
was stoked for when certain women played
there I was elated elated that fancy
dance was scheduled for Eccles and to
know that it's sold out because when
you're making films like this you're so
you're so often told this is you know
this is a great script but we can't make
it you know this is a great project
great idea you know keep going but you
know it's not for us but then you see
the echo sells out and there's that many
people who were there embracing it like
hanging on every breath like all the
gasps when like with the gun moment
um the suspense that you know when
you're shooting something in an
unsegmented way you hope is there but
does translate and then hearing how
suspenseful it was for the audience and
feeling that it just it's like here's a
here's thousands of people who say yeah
we care about this we're here for this
so it was um it was just you know I
guess just a very just thing that it
played there and that it played to a
sold out audience there
yeah
is there anything you wanted to add
just
yeah the energy in the audience was
amazing like the gasps were my favorite
thing ever like they were so amazing
they're great and then Lily and I were
sitting next to each other and it was
kind of I was only paying attention to
Arrow like it was just us watching the
thing that we made and yeah it was just
really really incredible it's my first
feature so getting to Premiere there was
so cool
yeah I can't imagine uh you cherish this
moment because it's you will you all
know you know um listen I gotta stop
here um uh uh I really would love to
have talked more specifics but because
no one has seen it yet I really just
wanted to avoid things for and but the
next time we'll talk more specifically
um thank you all so much for coming in
and have an amazing Sundance and I'm so
happy for you guys thank you so much